-How about we kick
that case to Madeline
and you help the deacon here
-The...deacon?
-Dick Wickware,
but people call me "Deafy.
[ Telephone rings ]
-You -- you deaf?
-I could see how you'd lea
to that conclusion, but no
They call me Deafy on a count of
I hear what I want to hear
And what I want to hear
right now is
you've gotten a dress for
the sister of one of my runners.
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Timothy Olyphant.
That was a clip from
Installment 4 of "Fargo."
-Installment 4, Chapter 4
of "Fargo."
-Chapter 4.
Dick "Deafy" Wickware.
That's a hell of a name
for your character.
And one of the things
we didn't see in that clip -
big fan of this character --
this character will take out -
Deafy will take out
little carrots,
carrot sticks
wrapped in paper towel.
-And you are just -- As far as
the acting of eating,
you are doing such a good jo
in this role.
-Thank you.
I appreciate you noticing.
I worked -- I've been
doing it for a long time,
and so -- I'll tell you,
it was lovely.
I didn't come up with
the carrot thing.
Noah Hawley,
the wonderful Noah Hawley,
who I'd go to
the ends of the Earth
to work with that guy again --
he had that written in the
script that my character, Deafy,
had carrots wrapped
as if they were, like,
neatly wrapped from his wife
as he cruised around
looking for these fugitives.
And then
I really appreciated it,
because,
as a lot of actors know,
if you eat while you're acting
it just makes you look lik
a better actor.
-Yeah.
Do you have any tricks for -
Oh, actually,
you got something right there.
Give us a little right now
-Oh. These --
They're not olives,
but they're so delicious.
There's something --
-See, I feel like
the commercial break
was when you should have
gone and Googled that.
-Wasn't much of a break,
to be honest with you.
I think the people
and the crew knows
it happened pretty quickly
I feel like
we're just getting started
and it's all almost over.
This is just so nerve-racking,
these talk shows.
Do you get nervous?
-Well, I don't get nervous
like, with you anymore.
Like, Bob Woodward's next,
and I might get
a little nervous with him.
-Oh, you got to tell him -
I want to talk --
That's the guy
you want to talk --
Why are we wasting time
talking to me?
-Yeah, that's true.
That guy wrote a book
about the president,
he won a Pulitzer,
and, yet, here, you and I --
Literally, we're just
chatting about nothing.
-This career's --
this is bull...
I mean, come on.
-Hey, you know, obviously,
-By the way -- Wait.
Tell Bob --
He's going to appreciate this.
I think he'll appreciate this.
I've had this dream, and it's --
-You can finish, but I'm not
going to tell him this.
Keep going.
-It's Kellyanne Conway,
Bill Barr, and Donald Trump.
Only, in my dream,
Bill Barr is John Goodman
and Donald is Buscemi
and Kellyanne Conway
is played by Jeff Bridges.
And he's talking about how
this guy, George Conway,
took his rug,
and the president keeps going,
"Conway? That's your name,
Kellyanne."
And then Bill keeps going,
"Donny, please."
-And that's -- So I should tel
that to Bob Woodward.
-"Donny, you're out of
your element!"
You know what's good about this?
I saw your monologue.
This can all be cut.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not -- No, no.
Because once you thinking
things on this show can be cut
there's no telling
where you'll go.
You have to know there's a -
-I noticed, when you told me
that Bob was coming on,
you didn't talk about
the award he won.
Go ahead and tell me that again.
-The Pulitzer.
-What was that that Bob won?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey --
-Ask him how much he got for
that, by the way.
-I want to -- What's that?
-Ask him how much
he got for that.
-For the Pulitzer?
I'll say, "How much did you --
Hey, how much did you
get for that?"
-Yeah, that was good.
-Like a guy
who's a little jealous?
Like, "Well, how much
you get for that?
-By the way,
how much you get for that?
-Congrats on the Pulitzer.
It must be some
pretty nice scratch, right
-Yeah, or make
him feel comfortable.
He'll be like, "Oh, this guy
really is a knucklehead."
And he'll feel good
talking to you.
-I do actually genuinely
want to ask --
end on something that
we hadn't planned on.
Very sad -- Eddie Van Hale
just passed away,
and I noticed you're wearing
a Van Halen shirt.
You obviously had this on hand
Greatest --
-I just learned that, and when I
heard the news I was like,
"Well, I'm breaking out
the shirt.
Okay."
-It's a very nice tribute.
Greatest guitar player
of all time.
-It's like the hits
just keep on coming, Seth.
The hits just keep
on coming this year.
-Yeah, they really do.
-But I'll tell you something
As Jesus said, you can't sto
the waves from coming,
but you can learn to surf.
-Well, I can't imagine
there's going to be
a better way to end
on it than that.
It's always a pleasure.
I mean, I was worried we weren't
going to have the same
rat-a-tat chemistry
we usually have,
but I think we put those -
-Did we have it?
-I think we had it.
-Because my daughter is righ
off camera and she's like,
"It's a little much, Dad."
[ Laughter ]
Because the note I'm getting
off camera is like,
"Right now, you're here.
Maybe just
bring it down to here."
-You know what?
I think I'm going to
rescind my offer
to e-mail you,
and I'm gonna e-mail her,
'cause I do -- I would love to
have a direct line to you
from somebody who's, like,
in the house,
you know,
just for notes and stuff.
-Listen, you can -- Yeah.
And, by the way, if you're
hiring, you know, let me know.
We could do it every day.
We could just do...
I'm jealous of anyone right no
with a job, Seth.
-Well, let me just tell you,
this interview --
best work you've ever done
The fourth season -- "Season."
That's what they have
on the card.
Give me a hard time here.
-Oh, my God!
-Sunday nights, 10:00 --
It's going to be
10:00 p.m. on FX,
available the next day on FX
and we'll be right back
with Bob Woodward.